que ha dicho el palacio de buckingham y
que es lo poco que se conoce
si maria clara como lo decías muy bien
hay preocupación en todo el país
nerviosismo por el estado de salud de la
reina isabel segundo de 96 años que
completó 70 en el trono el palacio de
buckingham hace un par de minutos
entregó un parte médico bien preocupante
y que no tiene precedentes porque hasta
el momento los británicos y el mundo no
ha tenido certeza de cuál es el estado
de salud de la reina salvo que ha tenido
problemas de movilidad como bien lo
mencionaba ha dicho el palacio de
buckingham después de una evaluación
esta mañana los doctores de las reinas
están preocupados y aquí es donde entra
lo inusual por el estado de salud de su
majestad y le recomendaron que
permanezca bajo supervisión médica
la reina permanece cómoda en el castillo
de balmoral en escocia donde como lo
mencionaba ha permanecido hace varios
meses y también en las comunicaciones de
clarence house que es la residencia
oficial del príncipe carlos que es el
heredero al trono revela el hijo mayor
de la reina y quién es el heredero al
trono del próximo rey y su esposa camila
parker están viajando en este momento a
balmoral así como el príncipe william el
nieto de la reina y el segundo en la
línea de sucesión para acompañar a la
reina en este momento por supuesto el
país está muy pendiente de lo que está
sucediendo con la monarca y la primera
ministra así como otros líderes
políticos a través de twitter han
enviado mensajes de pronta recuperación
a la monarca lis atrás ha dicho todo el
país está profundamente preocupado por
las noticias mis pensamientos y los de
todo el país están con su majestad y su
familia el último día que vimos a la
reina fue hace apenas dos el martes
cuando a recibió a lis atrás en el
castillo de balmoral para pedirle que
nombrará que formará un gobierno en su
nombre vimos a la reina isabel un poco
débil con un bastón en su mano pero
profundamente sonriente y dándole la
bienvenida a su prima a su primera
ministra número 15 en estos 70 años de
reinado graciasluis ahí nosotros
seguiremos atentos cómo avanza la salud
de la monarca